Now we all know what saving a game means.
It's the underlying functionality that allows a player
to save the current state of the game,
close it and come back and resume where they left off.
But what really constitutes a current state of the game
is really gonna vary from project to project.
Thankfully, Unreal offers a flexible save system
that allows us to store a plethora of information
about the game and also allows the player
to have multiple saves for this particular game
in different slots.
So really the main question is how extensive
do you need your save game to be?
Saving and loading a game can both be done in native C++
and also in blueprint.
And it's important to note that whilst both methods
offer a synchronous and asynchronous way
of saving and loading, the native C++
also offers explicit synchronous binary
saving and loading methods.
Saving and loading a game in either native or blueprint
follow a very similar flow and set of steps.
For the purposes of this talk,
we'll be talking about them in very general terms.
However, the Unreal Engine documentation
has got a great example of how you can achieve
both loading and saving either synchronously
or asynchronously.
First thing we need to do is create a new save game object.
In native C++, this would be done by creating a new class
that inherits from the use save game type.
In blueprint, we can create a new blueprint class,
then select the save game parent class
to base our new blueprint from.
Next, we need to choose what data we wish to store
in our save game.
For example, we may need to store the last known location
and rotation of the player.
In this case, we would declare two new variables
of F vector and F rotator types.
Alongside the data that you wish to store,
we also need to define two key pieces of information
that will allow us to save and load our save data.
The first is just a string
that represents the save slot name.
And the second is an integer
that signifies the save game index.
The gameplay statics library provides three key functions
to both native and blueprint
that allow us to save and load our game.
And those are the create save game object.
This function takes in a class for your save game.
This will be the class of your new save game object.
And this function will return you
that newly created save game object directly.
Next, we have the save game to slot
and async save game to slot.
These functions require the following data
to save your game.
That would be in the save game object itself,
the save game slot name,
and lastly, the save game index.
Lastly, we have the load game from slot
and the asynchronous load game from slot.
These functions require both the slot name and the index
in order to retrieve the same game object
that holds your saved data.
It really is important to note that it's advised
that you make use of the asynchronous versions
of the save game and load game functions
to avoid any hitches on your game thread.
Furthermore, the asynchronous version
will provide a callback function
which not only return the save game object,
but will also let us know
whether or not the procedure was successful or not.